The stories we tell ourselves,
echo affecting our behavior and what our
future stories will eventually say.
Rebounding from expectations to action,
bringing to life.
We are creatures that live on
narratives,
entertained by the stories we hear and
directed by the stories we believe about
ourselves and our world.
For example,
if you're convinced you're not a runner
and you don't enjoy running,
you will prove yourself right because
you're unlikely to lace up every morning
to run.
If you don't believe the goal you're
chasing is attainable and that will lead
you to drop out of high school cross
country after less than a couple of
weeks,
siding dubious claims of an inability to
get up early enough in the morning.
Alternatively,
if four years later,
you're a silly experiment in college kid
and you try playing a sound bite in your
head everyday that despite your history
of failure at rapid bipedal locomotion,
you're actually a runner at heart and
you love it.
In that case,
since you're a runner who loves running,
you're probably going to get out there,
which given a few months training will
make your fictional narrative come to
fruition.
I'm bringing this up because it's
valuable to know that to some extent you
can decide what stories you believe and
in turn live with meaning.
If you want to say pick up the guitar,
it might be worth mentally doing some
work to tell yourself a story that
you're a guitar player instead of
thinking of yourself as just another
person with a guitar in the closet.
This shift in mindset,
if you believe it can have a profound
impact in the way that you relate to
that instrument and how much you
practice over the next few years.
It's worth noting here that this isn't
some secret that will miraculously make
you able to achieve anything.
This is just a way to use the power that
stories have in making our identity to
help you get into the right type of
behavioral patterns for the results you
want.
More than just at the beginner level
though at the highest level of
competition and performance,
storytelling seems to matter the most
because there's a level of focus
required that almost demands a narrative
that has nothing to do with reality.
Here's Arnold Schwarzenegger talking
about this concept on Tim Ferriss's
podcast for how he won his first junior,
Mr Europe.
It was so clear to me that you were
going to win and that you knew or
believed you were going to win.
Your face was so confident.
Where did that confidence come from?
My confidence came from my vision.
If you have a very clear vision of where
you want to go,
then the rest of it is much easier
because you know always why you training
five hours a day,
you always know why you pushing and
going through the pain barrier.
I see myself clearly on that stage
winning the Mr Universe as cms itself,
very clearly of getting the trophy,
standing,
debit the trophy,
raising it above my head,
and having hundreds of bodybuilders
around me on stage,
uh,
looking up and idolizing me,
including the thousands of people that
are watching the event.
So there was always made clear vision
and that always inspired me,
uh,
to go all out.
Now he relates to this concept through
visualization and vision,
but this is just the kind of
storytelling about the future and this
deliberate storytelling was the key to
his success because before he had won
first competition,
if you were an outsider looking in,
arnold had no reason to be that
confident except for his internal story.
He was enrolled in the military,
he was poor,
and he wasn't bodyboarding full time.
Most impartial observers would have seen
his dream is a bad bet,
but you can't train five hours a day on
a bad bet.
You can only train that much if you
believe that you're destined to be
number one.
And he believed that and because he
believed that he trained as if it were
true,
eventually making the story as true in
the real world as it was in his head.
Now this doesn't just apply to athletics
or skills,
that's just a sphere where it's easiest
to see how this works.
The same is true of our beliefs about
the world.
If you tell yourself that the world is
cruel,
you might subconsciously explain away
good things happening is just setting
you up to fall harder to later and
explain bad things happening as part of
a raked chaotic system that inexorably
is leading you to a cold grave.
You can also tell a much different
story,
but the world is on the whole good,
which will lead you to a much different
interpretation of the data,
a much brighter and happier
interpretation I might add.
And it's your choice.
What narrative you believe,
even in the face of seemingly difficult
experience.
Take Malala who chose to believe in a
narrative of love and forgiveness even
after being attacked by the Taliban.
So you were shot in the face at 15 years
old and you have no anger towards the
man who shot you.
How is that possible?
I think they made a big mistake,
um,
because I was fighting for the right of
education right from the beginning when
the Taliban stop cars from going to
school.
But I had this little bit of fear that
what would happen to me?
How would I feel if someone it takes me.
But after that incident,
when I was attacked,
that fear just went away.
And as I said in my speech at the United
Nations that my weakness,
my fear and my hopelessness died on that
day and I became stronger than before.
Rather than responding with rage,
she uses it as fuel to double down on
her courage,
belief and hope for the world.
Just like in the world of skills,
the philosophical narratives you
subscribed to have affects on more than
just the internal interpreted experience
because that interpreted experience then
bins back and behaves in the world.
So if you expect the bad,
you might just experience more of it
because you find yourself frowning at
others,
suspecting them and being guarded.
Conversely,
if you expect the good,
you just might find it like Malala did.
Stories we tell ourselves are more than
just important fables.
They make up the fabric of our identity
and influence the dance of the main
actor in our story.
So listen,
look and read broadly.
But we have to carefully curate the
stories in our libraries that we tell
ourselves.
Knowing that the next chapter will
reflect the last one we read.
Curiously,
the idea that you can change your future
story by believing a different one is
itself a kind of narrative.
Is this idea nothing more than an
idealistic fairy tale or will you add
this to your library?
It's up to you.
I haven't gone in a quick thank you to
those of you who have supported me on
Patrion.
Thank you for allowing me to tell
stories that I think are rich and
valuable.
These are the stories in my library.